here now with more chairman of the house
Judiciary Committee Jim Jordan and
Florida Congressman Matt Gates is with
us thank you both thank you Congressman
Jordan
you know
had an impeachment
over one hearsay whistleblower yeah you
you said you've never seen anything like
this in your life dozens and dozens of
whistleblowers coming forward not
Republican or Democrat what are they
telling you
no you're exactly right son I think this
is important point this is not
Republicans this is not conservatives
it's not Matt Gates and Jim Jordan This
is dozens of FBI whistleblowers coming
to talk to us and they first came to
talk to us while we're in a minority
where all we could do was begin to get
the facts begin to tell their story and
many of these individuals have been
retaliated against and they're they're
good people just like Nicole Parker and
Thomas Baker who testified today the
first one came for his deposition on
Tuesday the next one is Friday the
thought the third one is next week on
Tuesday we learned about what Sarah
reported 140 people come to the rally
here in Washington DC and they were
supposed to be investigated because the
Washington field office told the folks
in Boston to investigate these people
for simply coming to a political rally
for goodness sake and thank goodness the
folks in the field office which Mr Gates
was just talking about the folks in the
field office says no we are not going to
investigate people for exercising their
First Amendment right and that's really
what this is all about so God bless the
good people who you're right to talk
about and the folks in the FBI who are
doing the good work like those Witnesses
we had today we are here to serve them
but make sure that the leadership is not
going up uh going after the American
people chairman let me ask you this uh
because Senator Grassley testified today
that they acquired the authentic Bank
bank records that substantiated findings
of their previous two reports and that
being that they financially have links
between Hunter and James Biden to
entities and individuals connected with
the Communist Chinese regime we hear
about a 1.5 billion dollar deal with the
Bank of China we hear about a five
million dollar no interest forgivable
loan we hear about a hundred thousand
dollar shopping spree with the Chinese
Nationals is that all true sir
well we'll wait for their report from
Senator Johnson testified that their
report is coming their second report
we'll look forward to that that's the
kind of information that I know chairman
Comer on the oversight committee is
looking to get he's looking to get
access to the suspicious activity
reports that supposedly there are 150 of
them that exist on the banking
transactions and records from the Biden
business uh family business operation
you know Matt Gates I liked your line
when you said you're not here to trash
the FBI but rescue the FBI from
political capture
um after James Comey and now Christopher
Ray and I said when Christopher Ray
became the FBI director he has a duty to
clean up the world's Premier law
enforcement agency clearly he has failed
in that task my question is can it be
rescued or do we need to rebuild a new
FBI one that can be trusted one that
doesn't take in political considerations
one that believes in Equal justice and
application of our laws
well if we decentralize the power
outside of Washington DC I think we can
vindicate the true and honorable and
just purpose of the FBI without falling
victim to political capture and Sean
it's every election before the 2016
campaign and FBI lawyer changed evidence
before a secret court before the 2018
campaign the FBI was breathing life into
the lying steel dossier before the 2020
campaign you saw the FBI doing
everything they could to make you think
that Trump was somehow a Russian agent
or shaking down Vladimir zielinski and
then before 2022 they raided Mar-A-Lago
all the while suppressing the
information on the hunter Biden laptop
and suppressing anything that was
derogatory to Joe Biden and when we let
the Democrats bring any human being on
the planet Earth in to say that maybe
the government isn't weaponized against
our people maybe Jim Jordan and I are
wrong they brought in a lobbyist but not
just any lobbyist a lobbyist that was an
obama-era doj political appointee who
now rep presents Google and Pfizer and
George Soros as a paid influence Peddler
bringing in a lobbyist to try to
dissuade us from our path to expose the
weaponization of this government would
be like bringing in Joe Biden to teach
your comprehension and cognition class
or maybe Chris Christie to do your
weight loss planning with you it was
ludicrous and we deserve far better exit
question uh chairman I'll ask you first
was there a well-designed and
orchestrated censorship campaign to
influence the 2020 election is that a
fact at this point yeah and I like the
term that Professor Turley used
censorship by surrogate here's a
fundamental question Sean why is the FBI
sending a list of accounts to Twitter
and telling Twitter we think these
accounts we think these tweets violate
Twitter's terms of service why are they
doing that if that's not pressure if
that's not coercion to take down free
speech to take down political speech I
don't know what it is so I like that
term censorship by surrogate because
that's what took place and we know that
because of the Twitter files Matt Gates
do you agree censorship influenced the
outcome of the 2020 election
undeniably on the laptop story alone but
we are just starting to learn all of the
different features of Shadow Banning and
trying to shape political thought for
people in this country I just want an
FBI that goes and stops the bad guys
from committing crimes and holds them
accountable when they do not an FBI and
Department of Justice that's trying to
shape the political thought of our
fellow Americans we can do that for
ourselves we can decide who we want to
vote for without the FBI and the doj
trying to manipulate the digital
Marketplace of ideas all right
Congressman Matt Gates thank you
chairman Jim Jordan thank you we
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else